we've been covering the NRA Trump Russia
story for months at this point and it is
stunning to watch how the public
admissions of the NRA have sort of
inched closer and closer and closer to
the initial report that we did and to
reset this for you back in February I
interviewed vivica Novak vivica Novak is
overseeing an investigative journalism
team at McClatchy DC and her team's
investigation was into money coming from
Russia - and through the NRA and into
the Trump campaign which would not be
legal because foreign funds are not
allowed to be used for political
purposes here in the United States for
American elections and there were a
number of mechanisms that vivica's team
pointed out that the NRA
appeared to be using to hide the sources
of that money but the McClatchy story
that we initially talked to vivica
Novack about was very well sourced very
very well done now the NRA originally
denied it altogether they just said none
of this is true it's not happening
period bogus story fake news in late
March about a month after we did that
story I did a follow up story where the
NRA did actually admit in a letter to
Senator Ron Wyden who's been looking
into this Democratic senator they did
admit that they do receive foreign funds
but they denied that the funds came from
Russia and they also denied that
anything illegal went on because they
have their political funds and their non
political funds separate now at the time
we talked about how a lot of those
assertions really didn't make any sense
and had very little legal significance
but at least okay the NRA was moving a
step closer to actually confirming the
story of McClatchy it now gets even
closer we have a new admission from the
NRA where they have now admitted that
yeah they have more than 20 Russian
linked donors specifically 23 Russians
or Americans living in Russia since 2015
this we also know because of a recently
release letter that they wrote to
Senator Ron Wyden that I told you about
a couple
weeks ago we now have more information
about that now you might hear me say
this and say David twenty three
individuals making contributions over
the last couple of years is very very
different than a concerted effort by the
NRA to funnel Russian money into Trump's
political campaign potentially in
violation of campaign finance law and I
would say you're not wrong but once
again baby steps towards confirming the
story four months ago the admission say
the payments weren't big payments and
they weren't political payments they
were for membership dues and
subscriptions to the NRA magazine it's
just so hard to believe that they're
telling the truth now since they weren't
telling us the truth
all along and the NRA seems pretty sick
of all of this they're saying listen
we've cooperated this far we're not
going to be saying anything else we're
not going to be providing any more
documents and of course they are going
to try to downplay this once again is
just little amounts of money for
memberships and magazine subscriptions
but the most important element of this
is that the story keeps changing before
it was well we received one contribution
contribution from a Russian individual
now the number is twenty three Russians
and Americans in Russia that's already a
drastic difference from what we were
originally told and what's really the
focus here and the possible area where
it becomes legally questionable is the
purpose of the donations because it's
legal it's completely legal for
foreigners to give money to the NRA for
a subscription to the NRA if they want
to do that sure if they want to get the
NRA magazine that's something that
foreigners are allowed to pay for it is
not legal however for foreigners to
donate to the political fund that the
NRA has for influencing elections and of
course the problem is that the NRA
appears to be commingling funds and that
gets back to vivica Novak's
investigation where what her team found
out was that sure on paper the NRA
maintains a political bank account and a
non-political bank account or at least
maybe not even formal bank account
separation but at least a cow
separation between that money but
there's every indication that they are
commingling those funds thus that legal
distinction becomes effectively
irrelevant so to be clear yeah I know
twenty five hundred dollars total which
is what it seems to be in subscription
payments that's not major
what's major is that the NRA now has
contradicted itself and fallen short of
telling both the truth and the whole
truth in a way that no rational person
should trust that the NRA is now telling
us the full story and what will we know
in a month
I don't know but very very clear that
vivica Novak's team was on to something
back in February that YouTube clip now
has I don't know a couple hundred
thousand views I believe and it's a
story that with every passing week we
seem to know more about send me your
thoughts about this and about the Syria
situation I'm on Twitter at D Pakman and
the show is on Twitter at David Pakman
show plenty more from Las Vegas Nevada
after the break today's episode of the
program is made possible in part by Cody
a new innovative cryptocurrency and
online payment platform that's setting
out to revolutionize how payments are
sent and received online what Cody
stands for is currency of the internet
and most Kryptos out there today simply
weren't designed for online payments and
the goal of the Cody crypto is to
achieve an infrastructure for online
payments that simple transparent
trustworthy instantaneous and scalable
which no blockchain for payments has
really achieved to date so Cody is
aiming to be that missing piece of the
puzzle a crypto and platform actually
designed with online payments in mind if
you're watching this on youtube you can
find out more about Cody
and their ICO by using the links below
the video this is not financial advice
and should not be interpreted as such
and everybody should do their own
research on any project that they're
interested in